[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the dark horse
podcast live stream q a 138 we are ready
to both rock and roll
so without further ado we're gonna do it
right we're gonna we're gonna be a bit
brief today which is a shame
uh because there are a ton of good
questions brief without being terse or
curt that's my objective
well let's see if you made it
i already have a bad feeling about that
but we'll see okay um
there was it was a two-way tie this week
for the discord question because there
are so many good questions elsewhere i'm
only going to go with one i'm just going
to go with the first one
although i think we've addressed this
other times what is the evolutionary
explanation for what is called adhd
i have a daughter with a diagnosis and
after reading up on the matter the
second d in adhd seems like a reach from
an evolutionary perspective that is to
say
disorder right
i'd love an evolutionary viewpoint on
the matter from a professional
yeah
uh we have
we have we have talked about we've
talked about a number of these
uh so-called disorders uh that are
that are medicalized that are treated
with uh
you know for-profit pharmaceuticals
and uh that are likely both uh at the
end or near the end of some naturally
occurring continuum which had some
reason to exist in a
a time before hypernovelty was so
pervasive uh and also there are likely
to be for this as with some of these
other things
reasons for an increasing prevalence now
yeah
my guess would be
that there is
a pathology
and that pharma has recognizing its
interests in selling more drugs
basically taken a pathology that is real
and narrow and may or may not be
successfully treated
with a drug over which they have
intellectual property rights but
that
one could plausibly increase the number
of people who have it by
correcting the definition correcting the
definition in a particular way
and so my guess would be most people who
have adhd
are
really suffering the failure of the
system to deliver
a
suitably
enriching environment of the sort any
ancestor until very recently would have
had
and so anyway you've got a system that's
broken in terms of it providing
something
meaningful and rewarding for a child to
do that it would want to do and in the
absence of that you see a pathological
manifestation but it's really the
environment failing not the kid
that said there could be
individuals for whom that's not true and
this
very often it'll be
if you take any sufficiently powerful
drug with cognitive impacts it will
disrupt a system so if you've got
somebody who's more active than they
should be and you dump some drug that's
different it will put them into hey
that's different mode and so you can
then
run an experiment say does this
particular compound have a positive
effect on hyperactivity well it changed
that child's behavior and the point is
well did that change last or did they
just simply accommodate the drug and
then go back to being the way they were
um anyway something along those lines
well i guess i object and we read about
this in the book as well i object to the
idea of should be and i know that you
use that term um within the context as
it is used by uh by modern medicine and
pharmaceutical industry but uh the idea
that uh children should be able to sit
still
uh facing forward and not move except
when called upon or you know when
they've raised their
that's weird that's very weird hey zach
you want to put us both back on screen
okay now now
now you guys know more about the way our
cameras are set up
do um uh
the idea that the school situation which
is generally the realm in which uh it
comes to the attend it comes to the
attention of parents that the teachers
just cannot navigate this with this
child who will not sit still
is anything like an environment which
children have had exposure to before or
really is something that children should
be expected to endure
is itself i'd say erroneous so uh we
also see you know it's interesting the
the person who read the question i think
said it was her daughter i'm imagining
her but it was a daughter uh who's been
diagnosed with this and it's this is a
this is a pretty uh sex stereotyped
diagnosis in general uh the girls get
diagnosed diagnosed with anxiety and
neuroses and get the drugs for that
and the boys get diagnosed with the adhd
and get the drugs for that which is to
say mostly speed
and uh you know boys
boys are more likely to be fidgeting and
they're more likely to need to be
learning through actually you know
bodily interface with the world as
opposed to taking things in entirely in
the abstract
and there's that doesn't mean that that
is not the same thing as saying
therefore all boys need to be medicated
unless what your goal is is we are going
to create an environment
and it's going to
maximize um
the you know it's gonna make the largest
student-to-teacher ratio possible with
as few
uh not particularly well-trained
teachers as possible not to say that
there aren't some amazing teachers out
there but we want to be able to uh have
you know maximize profits and uh
minimize the confusion in the classroom
well that's going to be we're going to
do that by making all the children be
most likely to be compliant complacent
and quiet and that is more likely to be
more like a
girl style of being than a boy style of
being and so if that's really if that's
your goal
then the environment in which you're
trying to get those kids to behave
you've automatically told you know
basically made at least half the
population of your classrooms
non-compliant and therefore at risk of
being drugged into compliance yeah i of
course
agree with all of that but have some
desire to defend myself against a
possible interpretation when i say
should that is a very careful
theoretician's self-defined should
in other words i'm not imbuing the
powers that structure these environments
with any right to say whether the child
is too active but what i'm saying is
that there's some physiologically right
level of activity and that a person
might indeed have a disorder that would
cause them to be outside of whatever the
optimal
activity level was and you know by
analogy they might have restless nose
syndrome for instance i have had that
one myself
um
but by analogy
if i say you know when a person's
temperature is too high
right this is obviously a reductive
absurdum but a person could say well who
are you to say what you know what's too
high and the answer is well i'm not
saying i'm not saying it's 98.6 is the
right temperature but i'm saying that a
temperature can be so high that you
can't function that's too high and so
it is possible that there are
kids whose activity level through
whatever
process
modulates this are really
too active for their own good i think
that's likely true and i think it is as
with all of these things a tiny tiny
tiny version of the people who are
actually being medicated into submission
okay i agree that's why just just like
just like you and i will say you know
trans is real and extraordinarily rare
you know anxiety you know crippling
anxiety is real and and you know on the
rise for you know because what's going
on um but you know much more rare than
the number of people
on on the anti-anxiety drugs would
suggest and the same thing with the idea
of
hyperactivity
like
well how about stop taking recess away
and
stop letting kids be safe by parking
them in front of screens and actually
enforce them going outside and running
around getting dirty and you know
getting them getting themselves
into little scrapes and scuffs and then
see how hyperactive they are for the
however many hours a day you expect them
to sit still
and listen to someone drone on about
like gender ideology or whatever the
hell is going on in schools yeah i mean
i agree that's why i
you know the game of pharma is always
you own a molecule you're looking for a
plausible reason to deploy it and then
you're looking for the broadest
definition over which it can be deployed
right it's a game it has nothing to do
with making people better off doesn't
mean that these things don't often start
with an actual pathology and then the
question is well what molecules in the
neighborhood and how broad can we make
the definition
first question from
darkwaresubmissions.com this week
throughout high school my cousin has
done very well making money on his own
from various business initiatives
do you think it's worthwhile for him to
get a business degree should he do
something else
thanks love you guys
it really there's a lot of specifics
that we don't know anything about yet
here in this question but in general i
would say you know a business degree
especially if you're talking about
undergraduate business degree has
at least historically very little value
and i don't see any reason to think that
that's changing now well and what's more
the person as described has proven that
they are in a good position to teach
themselves so really the question from
the point of view of a degree is a
is the degree
uh does it contain stuff of value that
you cannot teach yourself well it could
be that it's compromised like everything
else and what you're going to learn is
the opposite of true
but even assuming that what you learn
with a business degree is true and
practical
there's a question about whether an
individual needs it because as you point
out a lot of this stuff is accessible
online somewhere and if you've already
you know proven that you can start a
business then it may be that all you
need to do is supplement what you know
with what you don't know and need to
know by many many online sources i mean
there's certainly there's certainly
there's certainly a real set of skills
to entrepreneurship
um
i don't see any inherent reason to think
an undergraduate business degree is
likely to give those to you
and i'm reminded this is this is on a
different in a different
domain but also in higher ed i went into
college
wanting to be a writer wanting to be a
science fiction writer and was a
literature major
and this is back in the late 80s and i
quickly
realized that the literature classes
that i was in
and the creative writing classes that i
was in um were not very interesting and
were not were not valuable to me and
what i really wanted was the reading
lists and i didn't want to have to sit
through the endless ridiculous
discussions of what we had read because
at least at that point in the school
that i was in those conversations seemed
banal and uninspired much much less
interesting than the similar
conversations i'd had in high school
high school that we met at in la
and but
the way that i formalized my decision to
actually go into science instead
which was something i'd always i always
done and was and do that i was good at
uh was that although i retained my
desire to be a writer
i needed to have something to write
about
and what i was seeing in the creative
writing classes that i was in was that
most of the
most of the short fiction that we were
reading
by each by each other by the peers
uh by my peers weren't about anything
because these were kids like myself who
hadn't lived who had who had nothing to
say
and so just just as you know in in my s
in my experience i thought well
if i want to be a writer i need
something to write about so i'm going to
go into something that i'm also really
interested in which is going to afford
me the ability to get places and meet
people and go to live in places where i
wouldn't otherwise go and therefore have
a lot of life experiences
about which to write
i don't know exactly what the analogy is
to business but it seems like there is
there is something there which is to say
okay going into business um per se isn't
itself all there is you know what what
kind of business might you be interested
in and might therefore art history or
biology or the law for instance be
the you know the right addition to your
native talent in in business now all of
that is said as if we have a system of
higher that is functional and of course
we don't and so you know that how that
advice changes in light of the fact that
there is no good university to recommend
for people at this point at least in the
us uh i'm i'm not sure and i wish i did
have a good answer but um but i would
say in general if you're interested if
you know if you have a demonstrated
knack for being successful in business
as a high schooler i would say uh my
temptation would be to find something
else to become expert in that can help
facilitate uh branching out into
business of a particular particular sort
well
i mean i agree with that except that i'm
i think we know a lot about what isn't
available in college anymore yeah and
to the extent that someone is
a
person
who teaches themselves well and has
skills in business it's possible that
the thing to do
is to bypass
the environment where they're going to
teach you that men can magically become
women and
you know all of the other nonsense yep
and you know business is at least a real
environment where you can guarantee
yourself that you can learn by
taking your understanding into the world
and trying to turn it into a profit
and if you're in
if you've got a series of successes you
can learn from those if you've got a
series of failures you can learn from
those and it's harder to convince
yourself if you fail
that you failed because someone was mean
to you sometimes that would be the case
but if you fail over and over again it's
not because the world is out to get you
probably it's probably because you're
doing something wrong
um now that you know of course luck
plays a role but um hopefully your
cousin having done very well so far is
not entirely due to luck
have you read the real anthony fauci by
robert kennedy jr if so what are your
thoughts could things really be as bad
and corrupt as the book claims thank you
yes
i have yes brett has could things really
be as bad and corrupt as the book claims
i'm afraid so
um
i
was that
that was a tough book to read
really really hard
and
one of the things i did as i read it was
just spot checked the references
it is incredibly well referenced as
anyone who's held the book in their
hands knows if you just listen to it you
don't necessarily know that but if you
have it in your hands it's typeset in a
way that's like it's actually a little
hard to read because it's so jam-packed
like the margins are tiny and it's just
so jam-packed with references so i
didn't look at even one in 25 of those
references but
every now and again i would look at one
that struck me as unusual or unlikely or
i tried i did occasionally do a half
hazard like i'm just gonna okay let's
check this one and see if it is what
what he claims
and i didn't doing that
which was
again haphazard i didn't find any errors
right so it's incredibly well referenced
in a haphazard assessment of the
references that back up the claims that
he makes
were valid
it is an extraordinary
um
what's the opposite of vindication
indictment indictment it's an
extraordinary indictment of
much of the modern
medical and public health and
pharmaceutical system
the likes about which we've been talking
for two and a half years and about which
many people
besides uh robert kennedy jr have been
talking about and uh
i have
also the silence with which the book was
met was remarkable i haven't heard
anyone
contest
anything in the book
probably there probably some of that
exists but i haven't seen it and
certainly
what seemed to be the response
maybe organized maybe not was ignore
this it will go away
um the other thing to say
is if you
look at what we actually do understand
what the evidence actually suggests
about our coveted response
it is the inverse
of the right response
the inverse is a very unlikely thing
to settle upon unless
complete corruption is the explanation
right it is possible to get a random
response through incompetence it is not
possible to get the inverse of a good
response
and
so
the
portrait painted
by the book
is consistent
with a system that misled i mean in the
u.s a system that misled 300 million
people
about
the right way to respond
to this virus and the nature of the
virus and so anyway that kind of check
also
suggests
a very dire situation yep
that's that's all that's all true i will
say i mean it's been a while
and i have notes i'm not going to go
into them now but there there are a
couple of points
one of the middling one of them small
where i thought it wasn't quite right
um but having
they were not on primary points of of
the book and again i was reading it with
as critical and i as i as i as i could
it's very long it's very dense uh but i
think uh
i think maybe one was the
characterization of the germ theory of
disease
uh which i just didn't find quite as as
careful as it might have been but i
think that was the that was the larger
of the two and again
it was just a characterization of
uh a way of approaching how we
understand uh medicine and science
rather than
a claim of fact none of the claims of
fact that i that i tried to fact-check
uh proved to be wrong
i cannot recall there was one
bit in it that i thought was slightly
uh was beyond what the evidence actually
suggested okay um
and
yeah it's been it's been some months at
this point yeah i can't quite put it
back together um but let's just say the
book is so encyclopedic
that the idea you know oh it has an
error and it's got a claim that's too
strong but how could it not right like
that that's not there's no excuse but
like you know a book this comprehensive
and that had to have been written so
quickly yeah uh is is going to have some
places that are not quite a perfect yeah
given how much is in it the
fact that it
almost entirely checks out is
really quite extraordinary
why can rocks work out while sleeping
answers below
so this guy provides an answer below do
you want to hear it now you want me to
wait
why can rocks work out while sleeping i
don't have it
because they get in shape by flint
napping
i wonder how chiseled they have gotten
since you read part one
terrible and i would not have gotten
there though i'm kicking myself for that
but
yeah all right yeah yeah
congratulations you're going to be a
father
might excuse me might icing an injury
sacrifice long-term repair for
short-term relief
ice interrupts the body's inflammation
process which i assume is an adaptive
one
you know i i was having exactly this
thought this week
conor this is from conor
um and i've had it before but i again
uh
again i was thinking like oh you know i
could i could ice this paint like no
i'm not gonna ice the pain and like
often i arrive and i'm not gonna ice it
because
i don't want to then feel the relief and
go and hurt myself again yeah uh because
we've been moving a lot of stuff around
and we're just like okay just take it
easy
already let your body tell you what
you're actually okay to do
but
specifically
yes even if you're not gonna then push
yourself the micro movements that your
muscles have
that they could engage in
without the inflammation
that the tissue was providing
you might do further damage might might
absolutely create a longer a longer
repair process and a more imperfect
repair process
uh yes yeah i've always been
suspect about the ice for 24 than heat
thereafter
it's possible that heat
is beneficial because heat is expensive
so you could imagine that selection
would have economized more than is ideal
that basically it could create a local
fever but it doesn't because of the cost
and that you could
supplement by adding external heat
but it's hard to imagine
why
you know i mean look i mean their
circumstances there are certain
certainly lineages of humans where cold
would have been hard to come by under a
lot of circumstances
that is quite right so the question then
is
it's good
but impossible to source so that our
bias in favor of it is
is not there that's quite likely yeah
well that is a likely pattern in light
of the fact that cold is very hard to
source
almost anywhere you go outside but it's
not cold enough to be useful yeah i mean
in in the temperate zone at any time of
year if you're near fresh water you can
probably get your tissues colder than
than they are but if you're in the
tropics you know any water is likely to
be somewhat cold
but it's not going to be ice cold well
but then that also introduces the same
logic as heat right if we are biased
against
i mean that's why i was bringing it up
when i think that both of these things
our body of mitochondria is on you
didn't you didn't say this part you may
have been thinking it but
let's say
that cold is good
your body does not say oh go out and
uh find cold to apply to the injury
um one reason if you you know let's say
you enter your shoulder yeah and you
need to put it in cold water in order to
get enough heat out of the system to get
the benefit well putting that much of
you in cold water is going to burn a lot
of calories to compensate you for the
heat you're losing and you need to be
doing healing you need to conserve
resources for healing right so it's
possible that this is one of these cases
like uh your tendency for your fingers
to go numb in the cold that's just out
of step with modernity where you have
plenty of energy available to add heat
or cold yeah
that's possible yeah that said
i do wonder whether the you know
the basic medical wisdom or lack thereof
has been inflammation bad right now
maybe that inflammation is bad well
there's gonna i mean there's gonna be
there will be occasions just like there
will be children who are actually too
hyperactive right there will be
occasions where inflammation like oh
actually that inflammation is going to
hurt you well that's gone that's out of
control maybe inflammation is by
definition bad but swelling is not by
definition inflammation
i don't know that sounds like a
plausible semantic categorization but i
don't know if that's how
they categorize those things right yeah
uh i don't either but my guess would be
swelling
is adaptive
and that inflammation may be
um
inherently negative but more limited
than we think and so we apply cold to
deal with
uh swelling on the basis that swelling
is synonymous with
inflammation and it just isn't yeah
that'd be my guess
yeah if if
yeah interesting yeah i think i think
that's right
okay
are polar bears white because evolution
has selected let me start again are
polar bears white because evolution has
selected for genes that make them white
or genes that make them the same color
as their environment so if the arctic
were purple would polar bears be purple
or extinct
well i know how to test this but it's
going to take some time and a purple
arctic
and damn the generation time on polar
bears it's going to be a long time well
so here's the here's the what
information we do have
it is that
the pigment that makes other bears not
white has been selected against so the
pigment has a cost
actually isn't
is this not true is it not the polar
bears actually have no pigment or is
that a different white organic
polar bears are pigmentless yeah so the
point is something that produces pigment
in a regular bear has been turned off
which is an economizing
feature as well as a color changing
feature which in those bears where it
was turned off and those bears lived in
you know
idaho
uh that didn't work out so well for them
yeah so
so anyway the point is it's standard
selection the point is standard
selection where the quickest path to
matching this animal to its environment
was actually turning off the pigment
that was present in its ancestor and i
mean you know it was is it a kind of a
simple toggle in this case like is it so
yeah it's so interesting that this this
particular story ends up being pretty
simple at the genetic level a simple you
know like on or off
and uh
those bears that where it toggles
whichever way is you know i guess on is
pigment so it toggles off and if you
happen to live in a in a white landscape
like hey that worked out for me right
now i now get i know
i know sneak up on seals more
successfully you do
now that i'm white
this has now gotten very dangerous why
did you become white honey
um yeah you always wanted a bear you've
been telling me that since we met
totally i think i mean it's not as
manageable as cats but uh but it's
cooler in some ways yeah don't let him
hear me say that yeah um
am i right am i remembering correctly
that bare skin polar bear skin is dark
under all of that uh translucent photo
that would be my guess
but i actually don't know that i know
the answer to that i remember do you
remember when our dog's nose molted yes
and it turns out that she had dark skin
underneath all that blonde fur yeah she
had she had a pink nose and then i don't
know your age or a year of age or so it
molted and it's got a dark nose now
what happened
um but i think i think it is dark
underneath and uh
which raises all kinds of questions why
don't you see the darkness through the
translucent why do you see it through
the translucent fur
um i think this is very thick
yes and the amount of reflectance the
amount of white light scattered by the
surface but from the inside a lot of
light presumably penetrates and the dark
skin would accumulate the heat from it
which you would imagine so it does get
through might not be able to get out so
you got sort of a
you got sort of a greenhouse effect on
between the skin and the fur yes and for
reasons that we are not going to explain
because it would be far too complicated
that does not result in the bear just
simply accumulating a lot of light so
that if you were to cut one open it
would
suddenly reveal itself to be gone right
exactly
right oh well that was fun okay
um
and and we don't know of any easy route
to purple purple fur so presumably that
would have taken a lot longer for the
arctic happened to be purple yeah yeah
everything would be different
yes everything would be different
everybody in the arctic would recognize
that it had come from a bottle and that
that was not a naturally purple bear
yeah well and that the arctic wasn't
actually purple
right yeah yeah bottle purple bears
okay um
is soil depletion from intense from echo
is soil depletion from intensive farming
cotton soy or corn faster in deforested
tropical soils
are they more dependent on fertilizer
love to you too yes 100 yeah 100 so
um
i i think we don't even need um
the intensive farming part right like we
just tropical soils
on average um have lower nutrient load
to begin with than temperate soil as
there are exceptions uh volcanic regions
being a big exception right volcanic
soils are very rich
rich in nutrients but in general like
the low like jungles the amazon um but
lowland tropical rainforests keep their
nutrients in their seed banks rather
than their soils and so you know this is
part of why
you know sweden slash and burn
agriculture works on small scale because
you you grow
uh you you you you burn you burn the
stuff that's on there um you leave the
char you you
i'm gonna do a terrible job describing
this basically
you till
the nutrients that were growing on the
soil into the soil thus getting them in
there so that you can grow your crops
and that lasts for depending three five
seven years something but then you've
got to move on because the soils are
just depleted at that point and you and
you go to an adjacent
spot
and then you move to another one after
three or five years and you move to
another one and after depending again on
precisely where you are and what's going
on with your soils let's call it 15
years you can rotate back around to your
original plot which has had time to
regenerate um if and only if population
density is low enough that there was a
lot of adjacent forest still to
basically seed uh the new plot so there
was good good solid secondary growth
already there that you can now swing
into the soil again so i i'm curious
about a couple of those estimates of
time it seems to me that
seven years is
too long i think seven is too long i
think i think three to five per plot and
then i
when i was looking at this and i think
this was from um
central american sweden agriculture um
15 to 20 years of cycling before you
cycle back to an abandoned plot was was
was about what but
uh you know again it's going to be very
particular to the place that you are
well it's also
subject so
you burn what's on it
you lose a lot of it as smoke yeah so
you don't get all the nutrients that
were sitting on it you only get a small
amount
and
the
you know 15
years how much has regrown so that you
can do that again and the fraction that
you recapture is enough and how long do
you get to grow on it you haven't
obviously regenerated a forest right
it's it's it's young secondary and um
what i don't know and what i think is
maybe at the heart of your question is
how many times can you do that yeah
right like so you know that you you
would expect that the amount of time
before you can come back to a plot gets
longer every time yeah
and so you know this this only works if
you've got intact forest right there
that can reseed and you don't have other
people having been using that soil in
the in the meantime actually i wonder
about the receding issue i mean
obviously that's an issue in general but
the question really is
um
a mature forest may be very low
productivity
right the trees may be growing very
little and taking up all of the space
the canopy right but the understories
once you've
cut down the canopy trees
the secondary scrubby stuff
may be highly productive yeah now i
think it's entirely productive
it may be that that's where the 15 years
comes from because the amount that has
accumulated in that time is more than
trees would have put on at that time 100
yeah because you don't um
if memory serves
and probably you know conor maybe but
you know some ecologists may know
i mean off the top of their head better
than i do um
the sort of incomplete burning of wood
into charcoal and trying to get that
into the soil is going to have a
different mix a different ratio of
nutrients than the fresh green stuff
with a little bit of wood and like in
the young in the young growth
and
in general it takes more and you're
going to lose more to smoke to get wood
uh you know charred enough to be able to
turn into charcoal to get dig into the
soil and so the newer stuff may actually
be uh it's certainly going to be easier
to
to slash and burn yeah uh and you're
gonna end up with soil that has less
chunks in it and you're gonna have an
easier time planting and growing around
it but you know what exactly it depends
again it's gonna depend on what you're
growing what the soils look like how
often they're you know if they're ever
flooded that's that adds a totally
different yeah
you know question you know if you're
talking about annual floods then it's
you're not doing sweden probably um like
in some parts of the amazon but if
you're talking about um you know
this landscape tends to flood once every
10 years or so
well where is it flooding from is it
bringing in nutrients is it coming from
you know if you're talking about south
america coming from the andes which are
volcanic and so is it bringing in an
influx of nutrients routinely
all of these things affect the answer
but
is soil depletion from intensive farming
faster and deforested tropical soils
the part of the question that's not
written is then in deforested temperate
soils
yes with all these caveats yep
yeah are they more dependent on
fertilizer
yes
great it's catching it's not it's not
like that
um
oh okay
can you run the thought experiment of
china the u.s
musk and google
all having an agi strategy
all having agi strategy advisors that
can trivially out think humans
what happens in the first weeks months
and years
well
i mean the setup to your question is so
far from reality
yeah that
you know a lot would depend on the
particulars
um
to what degree do these you know
one thing you could do to source your
uh to refine the questions so it's
easier to get to an answer is they all
sourced their agis from the same place
because the problem is that what
dominates your question the way
you've set it up is the difference
between
the agi advisors um
yep but if they were all the same
because somebody discovered it and sold
it to all sides what would that do
and
then it's a question of how does what
each of these entities is asking you to
do like that you've controlled for the
other variables yeah and uh
yeah i mean unfortunately you gotta you
do you you do need more variables out of
the equation before this becomes
tractable
because the various things are
presumably the various entities are
presumably asking
the agi for different
um
objectives well exactly i was just going
to say like what we don't we don't have
the initial
ask here which you know in a
basic science question like what's the
observation like what
what in this in this thought experiment
would china the u.s musk and google
be wanting from the output like what is
each of their goals and if they're if
their goals are
not related to one another um then the
question becomes like how long do each
of them go before they run into the
others
the others process well you can do
google and musk pretty easily
because google presumably asks for a
more concentrated form of evil
and musk presumably asks for
better memes i would imagine oh no
better flamethrowers
uh
the use of flamethrowers in memes
possibly but he wants uh more and better
memes and he wants them to get to mars
before anyone else was due the memes
yeah first to mars right means to mars
um
yeah china might care about that too
though first memes to mars first
mars um
i don't know that they're big on the
memes i mean i think they're big on us
being big on the memes because that
keeps us from succeeding yeah yeah yeah
they want us to think that it's all
about the memes mm-hmm
okay well that was the thing
a warning that time
this is exactly why i thought china
cares about the memes but uh no they
want us to they want us to care about
their names yeah they do
yes that is exactly what tic toc is
okay um so many good questions here five
hour oh this is not a question five
hours
five hours ago
probably at this point five hours and
five minutes ago five hours ago i saw
the ups guy make the drop since then
i've donned my pfizer shirt the
breakthroughs never stop happy to be
repping your cheeky anti-authoritarian
apparel
hell yeah thank you militant moderate
um here's another just comment thank you
bretton had there i've been compared to
vermin and diseased by the unjabbed when
i listen to your podcast i feel like my
civil rights are intact human again
yeah the vermin thing yeah that's a
rough one yeah
is catching up on sleep a thing if i
sleep four hours the first night then 12
the next is that equivalent to sleeping
eight and eight why or why not
no uh well wait yes catching up is a
thing
no it's not linear
and you can't actually catch up
oh
i we would have to define terms but it
is definitely true
that you are compromised after not
sleeping
yes and that
you are rejuvenated by nights of sleep
that are
complete
yes but that's not the question
if you sleep four and then you sleep
twelve is that like sleeping eight and
eight no no and the answer is um and
again i didn't see this coming so i
don't have the research at my fingertips
but um there's some there's some
actually good sleep research happening
now and um it's like much research does
tend to towards the reductionist and so
there's tracking of you know a few
particular parts of the brain
uh and and things in the brain but uh it
seems that there are long-term effects
from sleep deprivation which just do not
get made just do not get made up even if
you know you you can't you can't say
okay if i need to sleep 56 hours in a
week
i'm gonna do that all on friday and
saturday it doesn't work that way you
certainly can't get ahead
and i would not argue that you can fully
regain we know that there are negative
health consequences from sleep
deprivation but the question is if we
were to measure just simple
functionality right functionality
degrades rapidly after
uh having too little sleep
and the question is does sleeping more
compensate you or is all you can do
sleep
the uh adequate amount and then
you sort of outpace
the deficit
and so
i believe there's nothing wrong with the
idea that there is some catching up you
can do
but that it is you can't regain
everything you lost you can't get caught
up
uh you can't get caught up uh but you
can mitigate the damage
no these are two different things you've
got instantaneous functionality right
how functional are you it is not the
case that if you have ever been sleep
deprived that you will be somewhat sleep
deprived for the rest of your life no
there are apparently long-term effects
on the brain i'm not arguing that there
aren't i'm arguing in terms of
instantaneous functionality how
functional you are lack of sleep
degrades your capacity to do for example
math yes right you can get back to
baseline it is not true that anybody at
the instantaneous
right at the instantaneous level you do
you do not
ever
fully recover the damage that was done
there is long-term consequence from
sleep deprivation that is not in that
but so the real question is are you
asking about the instantaneous
well-being or are you asking about the
long-term damage and the answer differs
depending upon which one of those you're
talking about i think that's a good
framing i think that makes sense
um
someone says the sound pitch problems
are across several platforms for several
content providers
also brett get yourself a cutrike
cat trike catrike
what is a katrika i don't know what a
trike is
i don't know i don't know
um
have you ever considered renaming your
show bretton heather that's my partner
and i have referred to you as for the
last two and a half years
um
brett is your cough an emontary
phenomenon
your hip injury sheds waste that is
using the prolongation of your cough to
mechanically shed dead cells
i do not
believe so i love the idea that's echo
again
dead cells
from my hip are leaving through my lungs
that seems
like the long way around usually
that would be well all right so i'm this
is this is a new idea to me
uh i am
two things yeah
you don't have
a way out at your hip right like you
don't you don't have you don't have an
injury you don't have a wound a skin
wound there so there's there's no way
out there
and i am
thinking of this research
that was done on frogs many years ago in
which
i can't believe i i can't believe i
can't remember i think what it was was
some researchers wanted to track frogs
and put a
dermal a subdermal tag in them
and they kept finding
the frogs with no tags and occasionally
find a tag it was just like out in the
universe
and they'd be like a covered frog poop
um
they were
actually
not
[Music]
no i've got so i'm conflating two
stories the one that's relevant here is
um
they got these frogs to i think i hope i
have this right swallow these
transponders so they were with them for
a while but they but they were losing
them and they were actually not pooping
them out
they their bodies were encasing them in
in
stuff and then they were emerging from
their bodies yeah now
frogs is different frogs frogs
their skin is a respiratory organ
rolex is different and you know they
only have two layers of skin to our
three like
i wouldn't think that you could you
could necessarily do that with with your
skin you're not a frog i'm not a frog
okay uh so
and but
you know
i don't know
necessarily how all the waste gets
disposed of i mean we know how the waste
gets destroyed i mean we know the two
usual ways that we talk about no but you
get look you've got kidneys and liver
right and the liver exports stuff to the
gut and the kidneys export stuff in the
urine so the question is why on earth
unless this was something so age
ancient and
resistant to refiguring by selection
the lungs is a terrible way to get rid
of these things right once you get it to
the blood
the liver and the kidneys have a way to
eliminate it if you export it to the
lungs you create a problem apparently
one
[Music]
that is uh interrupting of
vital
functions yeah inelegant is all hell so
the only way
that makes any sense
is if it's a holdover from some
incredibly ancient ancestor
uh and i just don't i don't believe that
that's likely yeah
interesting interesting idea though yeah
yeah
okay uh is global
is global warming falsifiable
presumably this person means
anthropogenic global warming because
global warming
and presumably
we're going to try to answer the
question that i think you meant which is
anthropogenic anthropogenic
climate change yeah
global warming you know it is or it
isn't and we have records
right and you know it depends on maybe
you can argue about where you want to
count and you know how narrow and and
averages for regions etc but um you know
temperature is a simple quantitative
measure
anthropogenic climate change
is tougher
um
no
it is tougher
whether or not it's still falsifiable
whether or not good one um
um spelled differently
yeah yeah it is okay go for it
here's the thing
falsifiability does not mean can you be
certain that it is false or not
it means do you have a prediction
that is met or not
and is that prediction sufficiently
narrow ideally is it the prediction of
only that hypothesis
right so there are better and worse
predictions but
anthropogenic climate change predicts
the retreat
of the glaciers
right
we can
measure that
it is not
a perfectly narrow prediction because
anthropogenic climate change is not the
only thing that predicts the retreat of
the glaciers right but you could
you could
then say it should correlate with this
measure right
so then we get into the question of a
model
and you could say if anthropogenic
climate change then these parameters
which we're adding to the atmosphere
ought to correlate with the level of
glacial retreat yeah or any level of
glacial expansion
so there should be a number of variables
that uh
that are that you have predicted will
change in a particular direction yep um
yeah
climate change
has the it sounds like it would be more
wishy-washy because it's it sounds um
like it's basically a two-tailed
hypothesis now it's like oh it changes
at all then it's changed like well
i don't i don't think that that's the
intention of of
of those who renamed it from global
warming because the fact is that
anthropogenic climate anthropogenic
climate change predicts warming in some
places and cooling in others and that's
just fine there's nothing wrong
scientifically wrong or suspect about
that like that you know it's a complex
system the earth and it's you know it's
gonna it's gonna change in one way some
places in another way others but you've
got to be honest you've got to lay out
what you predict is going to happen and
then keep track of whether or not those
things happen over time and hopefully
you have 5 10 20 40 measures that you
have laid out and said okay
i think it's going to go this way and
frankly the direction of the change that
you predict
is more important in my mind than the
scale of the change than the magnitude
of the change and
i'm not just saying that because man
have they been off uh man have many of
the predictions been off with regard to
the scale but the direction still is
looking the way
the way the predictions have gone i have
predicted uh that said
uh
non-anthropogenic climate change
uh
i i do not know
well enough
where the predictions differ between
anthropogenic and non-anthropogenic
climate change and to me that's the crux
of the matter like that's that's what
that's what i want to see laid out very
clearly so that i can have a sense of
like now i know what to look for with
regard to falsifying one or the other
well
be that as it may
the basic problem with the question is
that it imagines that falsification is a
more direct process than it generally is
is it falsifiable yes
many of the things that we come to
understand we understand because
predictions that do not test an entire
model turn out either to be true or
false
and so
this is like any other
the model makes predictions some of the
predictions overlap with
non-anthropogenic climate change
some of them do not
but is it testable uh is it falsifiable
yes yeah of course it is okay
we've been going out for a while zach
just about an hour okay let me pick up
two more here quickly and apologies
uh
for
missing many of the questions
is covet over because midterms are
coming up no if covet is over because
midterms are coming up why are they
hyping up monkey pox what's the
difference
well of course there's an assumption
built into the first part of the
question yeah uh i i think covet covet
is over which it's not um
it in part uh because
people were not gonna put up
anymore with as much
down going into the fall when things are
likely to get ugly again covet wise
as uh as they whoever they are might
have wanted yeah i would i would put it
differently um
i think we have
substantially beaten expectations in
blunting their propaganda campaign and
while the costs have been
astronomical
their ability to sell that garbage
is
much lower than they had hoped because
there were an awful lot of
competent courageous people
ready to say actually this is my area of
expertise and here's why what they're
telling you doesn't add up and you know
i just don't think they expected it so
you know one answer and i don't know
what the story is on monkey pucks i
think there's some very conspicuous
things about monkey pucks being the next
problem
that make me wonder but nonetheless
let's assume that this is
just what it appears to be
the fact is
it
is a new topic
which the score is reset and
um the
the oracle and
all of the things associated with it
are in a much better position on a new
topic than they are on a topic where
they have been embarrassed again and
again
yep
okay uh
i'm forwarding a couple of these
questions to our next session just so i
don't lose all of them but i'm going to
do one more and then a comment
do you have any thoughts on rudolph
steiner's view on teaching children how
the human being relates to the animal
world via head trunk and limbs
how can i deepen this homeschool lesson
we love biology
so i went to this one not because i have
an answer because i don't know exactly
what steiner teaches on this on this
front but in general
i find
steiner's approach to education
extraordinary and you know he didn't
i don't i don't know
actually i would have to go back and
look a few of these really remarkable
educational thinkers from the early mid
20th century
were either unaware of or explicitly
unevolutionary
in their approaches and that limited i
think what uh what they could do i don't
think that was the case for steiner but
i'm not totally sure
so uh you know if if it feels
again i don't know this you haven't said
enough here for me to know or for either
of us to know unless you recognize what
is being referred to here
teaching children how the human being
relates to the animal world
basically if you're talking
via head trunk and limbs is what you've
written here if that if that
is what it could sound like which is
basically finding
um the similarity and uh you know more
power too if you can talk about where
the similarities actually do to shared
history and where the similarity is due
to um due to convergence that's you know
fabulous that's gravy but um absolutely
you know if you've got
if you've got a cat or a dog or just
look outside at you know squirrel or
deer or something and say okay you know
those four limbs are our four limbs and
we use them for different things and you
know we went upright and now we've got
things that we call two feet and two
hands but it's the same origin same
history for those four limbs that's
fantastic yep i agree i'd like to know
more about what you talk yeah and then
finally uh this
fyi
i submitted a freedom of information act
request to the
niaid that's the agency at nih that
fauci heads i submitted a foia request
to niaid requesting all communications
regarding ivermectin and covet 19. i
received 158 pages of completely
redacted meeting notes
[Laughter]
lipstick mark on it and did it appear to
match tony fauci's lips
oh my god
yeah
uh these are
i don't know these are not serious times
we live in these are very serious times
we live in both
both of those things they're interesting
yeah they are interesting they're
interesting
okay i think that's it for us uh for
this week guys
we will uh again brett's conversation
with uh norman fenton will be coming to
you next week at this time or at uh
midday saturday pacific time next week
and then we will be back the following
week
for a full episode q a all that
and also by then we'll be about to be
doing our private q a so we encourage
you to come over to my patreon and join
and get access to our private q a and
come over to brett's patreon and if i
can ask you a personal favor yeah
the algorithms
do not
they don't like it when we take a break
this is not a break that we want to take
but we're going to take it because we
have to our producer is going to be out
of the country out of the country
so if you would do us a favor and
circulate
an episode some clips some clips that
would be great that would uh help to
counteract the
punitive instincts of the algorithm
to say oh they're not here they must be
dead
right that's the story it tells
it's like what our dog thinks when we
leave for a day yeah except in the case
of youtube it's wishful thinking yes and
our dog would miss us our dog would
definitely miss us she's so grateful
that we're not dead every time we come
in the door yeah youtube however not so
much damn not dead yet
nope
not dead yet i'm not going to be next
week either but we won't be here
so
we uh we thank you for your support
and uh encourage you always to be good
to the ones you love eat good food and
get outside be well everyone
you